ah
bienvenidos a elecciones 2022 un tour
por francia en que analizamos los
principales temas de la campaña
electoral francesa tomamos ahora
dirección hacia el sudoeste francés
[Música]
y estamos nuevamente junto al mar pero
esta vez en la costa atlántica francesa
en el pueblo de sus acciones
aquí los habitantes que nos envían las
consecuencias del cambio climático el
aumento del nivel del mar es una amenaza
constante
a
la prioridad es la economía en
detrimento del medio ambiente siempre ha
sido así y esto debería
[Música]
aquí vamos a restar y liz ar para
revegetar y preservar esta reserva de
arena aquí en lugar de dejar que vuelva
al mar
nos quedan menos de una década para
poder reaccionar y cambiar radicalmente
nuestra trayectoria si los debates no
están a la altura podemos preocuparnos
de lo que ocurra en el próximo gobierno
en francia el calentamiento global está
provocando cada vez más olas de calor
incendios forestales e inundaciones en
el año 2015 el país impulsó el acuerdo
del clima de parís para limitar las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
pero qué está haciendo hoy francia para
luchar contra el cambio climático en
2015 el acuerdo del clima de parís fijó
un objetivo mantener el alza de las
temperaturas en 1,5 grados celsius y
aquí a 2100 y disminuir en un 40% las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
de aquí a 2030 por el momento francia no
está en condiciones de respetar esos
objetivos 63 por ciento de la energía
que consume proviene de combustibles
fósiles es decir carbón petróleo
etcétera y su extracción significa
emisión de dióxido de carbono hasta 2020
la producción de la electricidad
provenía en un 67 por ciento de la
energía nuclear recientemente el
presidente manuel macro anunció la
construcción de nuevas centrales
nucleares en los próximos años una
política distinta a la de alemania que
hace 10 años inició una salida total de
la energía nuclear o de suecia que cerró
la mitad de sus reactores a comienzos de
la del 2000 pese a ello algunos
progresos han tenido lugar en francia en
el 2020 la producción de electricidad
disminuyó en un 7% con respecto al 2019
un récord en 20 años por su parte las
turbinas eólicas se convirtieron en la
segunda fuente de producción de
electricidad sobrepasando a la térmica
[Música]
la señal en este edificio construido los
60 fue evacuado en el 2014 debido al
peligroso aumento del nivel del mar es
un símbolo de la batalla de francia
contra el cambio climático y allí nos
encontramos con justine de ripoll jefa
de campaña de nuestro asunto de todos
los cafés a tus
[Música]
justine de su organización nació en el
año 2015 el mismo año en que se logró el
acuerdo del clima de parís siete años
después francia ha cumplido con su
compromiso climáticos para la fosa
napster y montajes de francia no ha
respetado en absoluto sus compromisos y
no soy solo yo o mi organización quien
la dice el mismo consejo superior del
clima que fue creado por emanuel macrón
y que es un organismo independiente dijo
que actualmente no estamos en el buen
camino hay también dos veredictos
judiciales que lo confirman la decisión
del asunto del siglo presentado por
nuestra asociación junto a greenpeace la
fundación para la naturaleza y el hombre
y oxfam francia y la decisión en el caso
gran santa ambos veredictos van en la
misma dirección
recuerdan que los objetivos del acuerdo
de parís son vinculantes que no son sólo
promesas y que actualmente francia no
está haciendo lo necesario para
respetarlos y se debe hacer todo lo
posible para avanzar hacia sus objetivos
y compensar todas las veces en que no ha
respetado esos acuerdos con usted
menciona gran parte de su activismo
ocurre en las cortes del proyecto más
conocido es el que se conoce como el ace
'no y 7 punto del siglo porque elegir
esta estrategia para nosotros es una
parte central del trabajo de la
asociación y la transición ecológica en
particular porque las leyes y el derecho
son realmente las reglas del juego si
queremos operar una transición que sea
ambiciosa que sea socialmente justa
tenemos que cambiar las actuales reglas
del juego eso pasa por cambiar la ley
antes de que sea creada pero también por
hacerla respetar y para eso las
asociaciones tienen que ir a los
tribunales y pedir a los jueces que
tomen decisiones ambiciosas y que
legitimen sus acciones y exijan la
responsabilidad de actores como los
estados que lo que permite este
activismo en las cortes que nos permite
por ejemplo el manifestar en las calles
suele firmar una petición
son cosas que van juntas y el asunto del
siglo es un buen ejemplo de eso este
caso se inició en los tribunales pero al
mismo tiempo en el espacio público con
un vídeo con influencers y una petición
que se transformó en la más firmada de
la historia de francia con 2,3 millones
de apoyos de personas que creyeron que
esta acción era necesaria
todo ocurrió al mismo tiempo que se
producían muchas movilizaciones en las
calles
manifestaciones masivas y todo eso junto
hace presión sobre las autoridades
y los medios para que hablen del tema
etcétera
todo va de la mano
considera usted que los candidatos han
puesto en el debate el tema del medio
ambiente
pero
para nada y es una observación que
comparten muchas asociaciones
ecologistas y que regularmente denuncian
en los medios de comunicación y en sus
redes sociales
actualmente el clima y la ecología en
general
no son un tema que se ponga en el centro
de la campaña de las presidenciales
incluso publicamos un barómetro que
actualizamos semana tras semana y que
trata de cuantificar esta sensación
esta semana 27 de los debates de las
campañas han girado en torno al tema
climático
este porcentaje no se condice con el
nivel de la preocupación de los
franceses y la urgencia de actuar nos
quedan menos de una década para poder
reaccionar y cambiar radicalmente
nuestra trayectoria si los debates no
están a la altura podemos preocuparnos
de lo que ocurra en el próximo gobierno
finalmente justine con respecto a las
políticas medioambientales que cambio le
gustaría ver en el próximo gobierno
francés
pensando en la línea de nuestro asunto a
todos para reforzar el impacto de estas
acciones legales y de la ley en general
y en particular desde el 2021
buscamos incluir la protección del medio
ambiente de la biodiversidad
y la lucha contra el cambio climático de
manera vinculante en la constitución
esperamos que no se quede una vez más en
promesas
sino que se ha consagrado en nuestra
constitución y sea parte del paquete
constitucional al mismo nivel de los
derechos y libertades fundamentales
muchas gracias justin ripoll
partimos 100 km al sur hasta llegar a
burdeos la capital regional
campeona de los atascos allí la
contaminación del aire sobrepasa a
menudo los niveles permitidos
[Música]
para mí el medio ambiente es esencial y
todo el mundo debe hacerse cargo
no sólo los políticos creo que si la
sociedad civil se preocupa de la
ecología y es cada vez más el caso
los políticos también se implicarán
en general todo gira en torno a la
economía porque vivimos en una sociedad
entre comillas capitalista y la
prioridad en la economía en desmedro del
medio ambiente y es siempre así y no
estaría mal que eso cambie porque a los
candidatos les queda menos tiempo de
vida que a los jóvenes somos nosotros
los que sufriremos las consecuencias de
una sociedad centrada en la economía
me gustaría que hablen más de ecología
pero como de una cosa en la que cree
no quiero que sea un tema oportunista
que les permita atraer a personas
sensibles al tema
a mí me interesaría que tengan
propuestas realizables inteligentes
claras una ecología de lo cotidiano y
que sean sobre todo realistas
[Música]
los pueblos y ciudades de francia se
están dando cuenta de que muchas veces
el cambio climático no es algo que
afecta a otros lugares y el desafío de
adaptarse a esta nueva realidad es a
menudo una carrera contra el tiempo el
reportaje de karina yabur
la canon capital del surf y de la
erosión
aquí la tierra retrocede en promedio 2
metros por año el mar se la traga
a este ritmo en 10 años la playa central
ahora ha desaparecido por completo así
que para proteger la duna se debe ayudar
a la naturaleza
aquí vamos a restar y liz ar para
revegetar y preservar esta reserva de
arena aquí en lugar de dejar que vuelva
al mar
este año el invierno ha sido suave y
estos agentes de la oficina nacional de
bosques están aprovechando para crear
reservas luego el viento allí viene del
oeste del mar lleva arena vamos a
intentar capturarla aquí porque porque
todo esto creará un colchón de arena que
ayudará a tomar las primeras oleadas que
podrían producirse algún día
pero ante las tormentas capturar la
arena ya no es suficiente en el invierno
de 2014 la línea de costa retrocedió 20
metros la ciudad tuvo que reconstruir el
dique urgentemente en los próximos cinco
años la ciudad tiene previsto eliminar
los estacionamientos y sustituirlos por
una explanada y reforzar su protección
la mesón de la gris el club de surf más
antiguo de francia deberá trasladarse
muy a su pesar
aquí estamos muy bien situados solo
tenemos que salir y bajar a la playa
por eso es importante que la mesón de
laglisse no quede en medio del bosque a
un kilómetro y medio del océano
la alcaldía promete que no habrá
reubicación sin el acuerdo de los
habitantes para ver la evolución de las
líneas de costa la alcaldía se apoya en
el trabajo desde el fin 30 costa cada
mes la fotógrafa realiza la misma toma
desde 28 puntos de referencia
aquí está el punto la fecha visualmente
no ha cambiado tanto pero ahora también
depende de las condiciones
meteorológicas porque no estamos a salvo
de una gran tormenta
el gerente de este restaurante no quiere
saber nada sobre el avance del mar que
nadie puede predecir que habrá una
tormenta por el momento todo va bien los
refuerzos están puestos no hay ningún
problema como el 150 negocios y 1500
apartamentos están en primera línea un
gran número de propietarios que deberán
ser indemnizados en caso de producirse
un retroceso costero un escenario de 450
millones de euros ante el cual la
alcaldía se encuentra desvalida por el
momento no se ha tomado ninguna decisión
política para el futuro ya que la ley
que se divulgó y promulgó hace unos
meses no permite responder a todas
nuestras fallas técnicas jurídicas y
financieras por tanto hoy examinaremos
determinadamente lo que ocurre a nivel
de la normativa por el momento no se
contempla la reubicación de otros
lugares
en pleno 'boom' económico la calle no se
protege de las olas a la espera de que
se tomen decisiones más radicales
[Música]
y
y hasta aquí esta emisión en llegó hondo
tomamos dirección hacia el norte próxima
parada nantes donde hablaremos de
inseguridad gracias por su preferencia